um what advice would you give to young
people you've done
first of all some of the greatest films
ever
you've
you've lived a heck of a
life
you've uh
we're fearless and bold and asking some
really difficult questions of this world
what advice would you give to young
people today high school college
about career
uh how to have a career they can be
proud of or how to have a life they can
be proud of
well i have three children so obviously
i'm not necessarily the best
best advisor in the world i
and they i do find that the children
i've raised them with a sense of freedom
and they do what they want in the end
it's their life their destiny their
character that's what comes out
you can try to influence it
but you see
you can try to get your daughter to wake
up at a certain hour in the day but it
never works you know uh
so i i i long ago gave up on that
and my children are all grown now but
aside from that i think
if i was a teacher in a school and a
teaching film i'd say to the students
get an education you can't just look at
film you can look at because it's not a
full education it's not the spectrum i
don't think you should teach film as a
i think you need a base
in other in other worlds one of the
greatest courses i took in nyu
was and i was a war veteran on the gi
bill so i was older than the other
students one of the great i took a class
outside the film school in greek
classics
because i hadn't had much history or
and i wanted to know more about the
world of homer and so forth and the
teacher opened my eyes to so much
in that class and i wrote about it in my
memoir it's called uh chasing the light
about this professor leahy and what he
did to me he just he gave me the
concepts clearly of consciousness which
is the homeric theme for of odisha
and
and also let the
l-a-t-h-e l-l-e-t-h-e which is sleep
and how most of the
uh crew odysseus's crew
were experiencing lethal and how
unnecessary it was to stay awake
uh so it's not just film it's just you
have to learn the world as much as you
can when you're young
and
so that i think is the basis of a good
education and a classic one is important
a basis i think then you go on and you
can learn computer uh if you want but
that's specialization you know
if you're a computer geek is that a life
does that give you enough satisfaction
do you get the joy out of
out of people
no just like filmmaking is a skill yes
right you need to have the broad yes
background to understand the world
literature yes
history
absolutely
you